[Music]
Falls
fore
[Applause]
jingle bell jingle bell jingle bell look
at this welcome to Norway you're
Americans yeah hi hello I can't believe
we inherited this place middle of
nowhere there's something in the barn
what do you mean
something so what do you think happened
probably some kids woo that's a barn elf
are they real oh my
God yes first off the barn elf doesn't
like changes to the farm that looks good
secondly he hates bright artificial
light what do you think and he hates
loud
noises motion activator
no this is really bad
you're in Norway now okay nothing bad
ever happens
here what's going on here we are under
attack where's your gun I don't have a
gun what this isn't Detroit
[Music]
Bill what on Earth did you do to make
them so M we broke all the
[Applause]
rules what are you going to do about it
I'm going to swipe this area for
fingerprints and then I'll call the
forensics and
uh